[Музика]
привіт усім, настав час уроку англійської,
мене звати Наталія лешка
давайте сьогодні почнемо ми продовжуємо розмову
про спорт, а це урок номер
три, давайте, тому для
вас є завдання, подивіться на картинки та
слова,
давайте переглянемо слова, тож якщо ми подивимося на
цю картинку, то що це за вид спорту
, ви пам’ятаєте, ми говорили про
камінь і мітлу, і ви вдарили
камінь, і він ковзає по льоду так, Браво,
це керлінг, а як щодо цього
що це за вид спорту, якщо ви пам'ятаєте, я
показав це ось так. Браво, це йога,
добре зроблено, що щодо цього,
це бадмінтон, добре, а що щодо цієї
жінки, що вона робить, вона катається на ковзанах,
добре зроблено,
що щодо цієї фотографії, що це за вид
спорту  це водне поло добре,
давайте перейдемо до цієї картини,
цей хлопець тримає биту, тому він
грає в крикет,
добре зроблено, а що щодо цього зображення, який
вид спорту це, попереджаю,
молодець, а останні два хлопці
грають в аерохокей  молодець,
дуже дякую, зараз давайте перевіримо керлінг повторюємо
за мною керлінг йога катання на ковзанах
аерохокей візьміть одні двері крикет водне
поло та бадмінтон молодці,
тому на минулому уроці я попросив вас переглянути
слова під диктовку, тож будьте готові, візьміть
аркуш паперу  або твій зошит ми
будемо писати диктант, а я запишу
слова на дошці, щоб
ми послухали слова та записали
я навмисне зроблю помилки,
щоб ви активно перевіряли давайте
почнемо давайте  буде
дванадцять слів, тож запишіть 12 чисел
готові
, є перше слово, слухайте уважно
Мет, тому запишіть його та подивіться,
моє слово правильне так молодець, давайте
перейдемо до наступного Гоголя і знову
Гоголя запишіть його  подивіться на моє
слово, чи воно правильне
ні це не так, давайте виправимо
помилку дуже дякую, щоб
вони були три літери G
правильна була гоголівська
G o GG l es дякую давайте з
наступною
ластами  і знову  ласти запишіть
це правильно так молодець давайте перейдемо
до боксерських рукавичок і знову боксерські рукавички
запишіть це правильно ні в
чому проблема зі словом боксерські або
рукавички рукавички так
я пропустив букву е давайте виправимо,
щоб ви бачили мій номер  1 був правильний, мій
номер 3 був правильний, тому цифри 2 і 4
були неправильними, тому давайте перейдемо до
гідрокостюма № 5 і знову гідрокостюм
запишіть гідрокостюм чи це правильно  молодець,
дякую,
давайте продовжимо паркувати і знову
паркуйся, давайте піднімемося чи правильно не
вчитель, що не так
ви пропустили решітку дивіться дуже дякую
, має бути подивіться, давайте перейдемо на палицю
і знову палицю, добре зроблено
перевірте мене, будь ласка, виправте, давайте рухатися далі
номер 9 шолом і знову шолом давайте
запишемо це, перевірте, будь ласка,
молодець, наступний готовий боксерський мішок давайте
запишемо
це правильно, дякую
, перейдемо до
кросівок і знову тренажер  s молодець
чи це правильно, дуже дякую
і останнє слово ковзани і ще раз
ковзани добре зроблено
перевірте слово, будь ласка, так є
помилка що не так
Браво, тому нам не потрібна e нам потрібна
буква а молодець, тому порахуйте правильно
бали подивіться один два три чотири
п'ять шість сім вісім тож у мене є вісім
правильних чисел, і я можу дати
собі вісім балів, а ви перевірте
свої відповіді, порахуйте правильні, і
це буде ваш бал, давайте
перейдемо до  малюнки,
що це за вид спорту, намагаються вгадати,
тому друге запитання дає нам підказку, з
якої серії книг вона походить,
деякі з вас можуть сказати, що це з
книг про Гаррі Поттера, а цей вид спорту,
ймовірно, квідич, тож давайте
перевіримо текст  подивіться текст
дуже швидко зникне, спробуйте зловити
інформацію, чи це про Гаррі Поттера, чи
це про квідич, подивіться, чи дізналися
ви інформацію так, це
про книги про Гаррі Поттера та
знаменитий спорт  ttich, а тепер давайте прочитаємо
разом і послухаємо текст давайте йти
Стів спорт блог
привіт блогери Я впевнений, що ви всі
чули про книги Дж. К. Роулінг про Гаррі Поттера
я великий шанувальник, тому я читав усі
вони  про хлопчика на ім'я Гаррі, який
ходить до школи чаклунів, а
улюблений вид спорту Гаррі - квідич, і
тепер ви можете грати в нього в реальному житті,
у моїй школі є клуб квідичу, і я
приєднався минулого місяця,
у квідичі все чудово їздить на мітлі,
ми можемо  Звичайно, не літайте ними, як в книгах,
тому ми бігаємо з ними
між ніг, ми граємо на трав'яному
полі, і в кожній команді є сім гравців,
один шукач, три Джейса, два
стукачі та один воротар, мета –
набрати очки
, це  робота переслідувачів вони намагаються
кинути м'яч через одне з трьох обручів на
кожному кінці поля, щоб набрати десять
очок, забиваючі намагаються зупинити їх,
а воротар
охороняє обруч на 18
хвилині снітч виходить у книжках
снитч є золотим  літаючий м'яч в реальному
л  якщо, хоча це тенісний м'яч у довгому
шкарпетці, який висить за шортами
снітча, шукач, це я, який
ловить снітч і кидає його
через обруч, отримує 30 очок, і гра
закінчується, команда, яка набрала найбільше
очок, виграє її  звучить божевільно, але
квідич — це найприємніший вид спорту, в який
я коли-небудь грав, і це також гарне тренування,
чому б вам не спробувати добре,
тепер давайте подивимося на текст
ще раз, тож перш ніж ми почнемо говорити про
нього, давайте з  невідомі слова,
тож перше слово — чарівник, давайте знайдемо його
в тексті подивіться, вони про
хлопчика на ім’я Гаррі, який ходить до школи для
чарівників,
отже Гаррі був чарівником, чи пам’ятаєте ви
її
Портера, так що він робив, він робив
cast  заклинання, щоб він був чарівником або
магом, також можливо херувим Нік,
давайте перейдемо далі
блискуче, давайте знайдемо слова в
тексті є Квідич клуб у моїй
школі, і вони приєдналися минулого місяця, це
блискуче,
тому клуб квідичу блискучий
або синонім до t  слово "блискучий" може бути
фантастичним для Дувра, давайте рухатися по трав'яному
полю, що це,
давайте знайдемо це в тексті, ми граємо на
трав'яному полі, і в кожній команді є сім гравців,
один шукач, три переслідувачі,
два гравці і один воротар, так що таке
трав'яне поле  трава Travie pitch Paula, так
що це діаграма для гри, чи
пам'ятаєте ви якісь інші види спорту, для яких ми
використовуємо трав'яне поле, правильний
футбол, добре зроблено, давайте йти далі, тому ми
маємо слово шукач знайти це в тексті
це те саме речення, яке ми  грати на
трав'яному полі, і в кожній команді є сім гравців,
один шукач, тож хто
шукає, давайте подивимося на саме слово
, я збираюся написати його на
дошці, щоб у нас було дієслово SiC Shikata,
щоб шукач був  людина, яка
шукає ловити м'яч, давайте перейдемо
до переслідувача хто це знову давайте запишемо слово, щоб було дієслово ганятися,
тому chaser - це людина, яка
переслідує м'яч або слідує за м'ячем
наступний відбивач давайте
це  ти можеш мені допомогти  зі словами
yes є дієслово to beat the bhavati,
так що з шквалом, наскільки це можливо,
давайте рухатися на обручі ви можете побачити це
на малюнках є hoop tilta, тому
давайте знайдемо це слово в тексті, через який вони
намагалися кинути м'яч  одне з
трьох обручів, щоб було три різних
гачка, і завдання полягає в тому, щоб кинути м'яч
через обруч і слово guard,
тож давайте знайдемо це слово в тексті,
щоб удар спробував їх зупинити, і тримати
обруч,
щоб вони охороняли  обруч, коли вони
розрізають Кулідж, що турбота має багато
непогашення сьогодні у футболі ми називаємо цю
позицію як воротар, ось
це охоронець, тож давайте поговоримо про квідич,
що нам потрібно, щоб грати в цю гру так,
коли на трав'яному полі нам також потрібні
інші  м'ячі в реальній грі був
м'яч під назвою снітч, тому м'яч
летів, тому що у нього були крила, а тепер
давайте подивимося на цю гру, щоб гравці
грали на трав'яному полі, і
не було снитча, який літав, тому
давайте знайдемо це  інформація в тексті,
як вони використовували це в книгах,
снітч – це золотий літаючий м’яч у реальному
житті, хоча це тенісний м’яч у довгому
шкарпетці, який висить за тими
ударами снітча, Ронна,
так просто, що вони ставили снітч
як  тенісний м'яч у задній частині
снітча, Ронна, добре,
зараз я хотів би, щоб ви записали
питання, які ви можете задати своєму партнеру
, другу чи члену сім'ї про
цю гру, я даю вам 10 секунд, правильні
два запитання,
тож давайте перевіримо мої два запитання
Буде те, що вам потрібно, щоб грати в
квідич, а друге, скільки
гравців у грі, ви можете
записати свої власні речення, а тепер давайте
розберемося зі словами, які я буду писати
їх дуже швидко, а ви спробуйте вгадати
слово перед цим давайте переглянемо це
все разом із тим блискучим
блискучим добре виконаним травою полем травою
шукачем поля ідеальним переслідувачем молодець
Пітер дякую обруч Браво
та охоронець дуже дякую
тепер слухайте мене я збираюся написати букву
w  Замовлення дуже швидко, і ви вгадуєте слово,
тож CH as er chaser Браво, давайте
з іншим H подвійний LP сподіваюся, що це
легко, давайте підемо до наступного
G ви є д і знову gu a rd guard
молодець, давайте спробуємо цей
gra SS grass яке друге слово
для цієї фрази grass pitch well done
hmm давайте з цим
w я встановив rd так, це майстер і
давайте отримаємо це слово de a te r і знову
будьте добре зроблені, а тепер спробуйте
вгадай це слово
BR i подвійний-l I a і T і знову будь нашим
i double-l int блискучий твоя робота також
блискуча, а тепер давайте перейдемо далі, настав
час вікторини, я збираюся трохи перевірити вас,
але цього разу ми поговоримо  про
прийменники подивіться у нас є
різні варіанти, у нас є чотири речення,
і нам потрібно вибрати правильне,
давайте, номер один, який вас цікавить
, або в кікбоксингу номер два, якими
видами спорту ви займаєтеся, або додайте номер
3, чи берете участь у
змаганнях з відходів  або в змаганнях і
останнє які переваги
пл  aying командні види спорту вимкнені, заявіть підказку
sports п'ять секунд правильні правильні
відповіді, і ми збираємося перевіряти зі
мною, тож давайте разом перевіримо слова, я також
збираюся написати відповіді, тому
номер один, щоб правильна відповідь була в тому, що
ми зазвичай говоримо  цікаво повторювати
за мною
цікаве це давайте запишемо, тож
давайте наведемо приклади чи цікавишся
спортом чи
цікавишся кікбоксингом ти зацікавлений у читанні
книг запиши власне речення як
приклад я збираюся написати також
я  зацікавлений у читанні книг,
молодці, давайте перейдемо до другого, у яких
видах спорту ти вмієш так добре, давайте
запишемо, які види спорту ти вмієш
добре я вмію плавати, я також добре вмію
йогу, а як щодо тебе, давайте напишемо
приклад  так гарна реклама, це не тільки про
спорт, ви можете сказати, що я добре володію англійською
чи я добре володію математикою, я також добре володію
історією, давайте продовжимо, чи берете ви участь
у змаганнях чи змаганнях
правильна відповідь у змаганнях, тож
давайте напишемо  беріть участь у тому беріть
участь у змаганнях
і ви можете відповісти так я чи
ні я не беру участь у змаганнях
але я беру участь у різних конференціях
ви можете сказати про себе я беру участь
у різних конкурсах  і ви можете
згадати, які з них спортивні змагання
музичні змагання чи будь-які інші давайте
напишемо приклад
я не беру участі в змаганнях
і останнє, які переваги
командних видів спорту або командних
видів спорту правильна відповідь вимкнена, тому
переваги  давайте запишемо, що
таке слово користь, означає користь, це
щось позитивне, тому позитивні речі
Парівар йому навпаки можуть бути
недоліками, наприклад, то які
переваги від командних видів спорту, як
ви думаєте, добре, ви граєте разом,
це командний дух
тож якщо ви не почуваєтеся добре, хтось інший
може допомогти вам у цьому гравцеві, тому будь-які інші
переваги хороші, тож давайте запишемо
приклад,
щоб командний дух був однією з переваг гарної
гри в командні види спорту  Ви
також можете записати власні приклади та
підготувати їх до наступного уроку,
тож давайте з домашнім завданням, цей
час буде дуже цікавим,
подивіться цей час буде досліджуватися,
тому ваше завдання полягає в тому, щоб знайти три незвичайних
види спорту, давайте  спершу подумайте про незвичайні види спорту,
що це,
наприклад, квідич – це незвичайний
вид спорту, тому що це не справжня гра,
це взято з книги. Я б попросив
вас зайти в Інтернет, просто Google, ніж
звичайні види спорту, вам не потрібно вгуглити
англійською, негайно спробуйте  знайти
інформацію своєю мовою російською
або українською, а потім ви знайдете
інформацію і спробуєте перефразувати
своїми словами, щоб скільки незвичайних
видів спорту вам знадобилося для наступного разу
три, і я вже можу вам підказати,
що це щось на зразок екстремального  прасування
прасування це брашов аня, так що екстремальне
прасування ви можете почати пошук з
цього, і наступного разу ми поговоримо
про екстремальні види спорту, тому я чую дзвінок,
і нам потрібно зупинитися  e урок
дуже дякую готуйся до
наступного уроку побачимось наступного разу до побачення
[Музика]
ти